SEMA misra was pregnant with her second
child when she was jailed in 2010 she'd
been convicted of stealing money from
the post office she ran in Surrey a
crime she didn't commit we lost
everything to be honest we lost the
business we lost everything
lost our dignity lost all Pride
everything
she was one of hundreds of innocent post
office workers who were wrongly
convicted and have now found out
prosecutors used highly offensive racist
language to categorize suspects into
groups now I think because of the they
had like from top to bottom they had a
racist thing in their mind so my case
might might would have been different if
I was an Indian they might not have
suspended me they might not haven't
taken the case I don't know the Scandal
was caused by errors in an accounting
system called Horizon that was installed
by the post office
the wrongful prosecution of more than
700 sub-postmasters for false accounting
theft and fraud has already been
described as the most widespread
miscarriage of Justice in UK history the
Revelation now that racist language was
used to describe people caught up in the
Scandal has added to their anger
many including SEMA have had to fight
and win lengthy legal battles to have
their convictions overturned lawyers now
want the racist language used by
prosecutors to be examined as part of an
ongoing public inquiry it demonstrates
dehumanizing of a process that's gone on
over a number of years in a a deeply
troubled flawed and culturally
morally devoid organization my clients
clearly want to see the inquiry
shed a light on these issues a post
office spokesperson said post office
does not tolerate racism in any shape or
form the language used in this historic
document is completely abhorrent and
condemned by today's post office but
after losing her livelihood home and
freedom for a crime she didn't commit
for SEMA the Revelation has added highly
offensive insult to the considerable
injury she's already suffered Becky
Johnson Sky News